jetzt sind wir fertig mit dem patient
mehr
dann haben wir noch die dokumentation
als wichtig schlagen genau richtig ja
munter 3 und haben wir die
leistungsphase die ist ganz wichtig weil
die rechnen wir nachher krankenkasse
unter pflegekasse genau du siehst sie
die leistungen die sind schon geplant
genau wir würden uns dann hier quasi
einfach nur eins sagen mit uhrzeit und
handzeichen büffel haben dass wir diese
leistung erbracht haben ja und du siehst
jetzt steht wirklich jede leistung drin
die wir bringen genau alles was so
außergewöhnlich ist wenn der patient
sagt er fühlt sich wohl an das ist so
gut dann muss das hier gar nicht drin
stehen soll davon gehen wir aus den
herrn bach ihrem partner versorgt der
ist super motiviert hilft mit man muss
zwischendurch impulse setzen wollte das
dann auch kognitiv nicht umgesetzt krieg
aber ansonsten wir uns eigentlich ja sie
machen das auch immer prima sagt sie da
sind dass das wirklich toll also
und da manchmal solche probleme aber das
ist wirklich nur super helfen
das freut uns doch zu laden
[Musik]
so kommen wir sehen uns helfen also
vielen dank für ihre hilfe
kein problem ist klasse
[Musik]